foreign
what's up Zach
hi Mrs Lonnie how are you dude I don't
know if I could be much better how are
you
oh man it's a hectic life that's all I
can really say for it sounds like you
were four beers in this morning already
you doing all right oh man he is so
currently
I already know my question I asked
before I it already changed because so
I'm going through a divorce currently uh
with my wife she has some mental issues
and stuff and I've tried helping her
over the years and then once we got
married and uh death do us part she took
a little bit too literal because that
because she started going on Rampages
telling me I hope you die I hope you
tell yourself I hope you I'm a truck
driver she's like I hope you die in your
truck
bunch of stuff and then talks as bad
about me to my son and everything but
I just trying to figure out what is the
next step to be smart because like I
don't want I want my son to see his mom
obviously but like she's bringing dudes
over that not like just that she's
sleeping with but my son's there or
she'll be gone for like a whole week or
like a five you know a whole week and
not even bothered to see her son but
then if I do anything and just
outlandish like she took my whole house
from me basically
locked me out of the house called the
police the police said you're just gonna
have to leave because if we come back
you're either we're taking both y'all to
jail or we're just taking you to jail
um what's the what's the current status
of the divorce did you just recently
file
yeah okay
um
rarely is it a hundred percent one-sided
what are you bringing to this that's
making things difficult
here's what I'm getting at because
I have a uh like a
I know my answer but I want to make sure
you can hold it so no alcohol no drugs
you don't got any problems like that no
you've never cheated on her or anything
nope okay
um then I want you to sit down with an
attorney and say I will not stop until I
have a hundred percent full custody my
wife's not well and the child my child
is in danger
right okay
and I want you to always keep in the
back of your mind that this is the
mother of your son so we're not going to
be ugly we're not going to throw
grenades we're not going to lie but we
are going to go to war and we're going
to get our our boy
because your son's not safe
okay yeah
and this also means that you're probably
gonna have to change careers
yeah I've already thought about that
yeah hey your son is worth
the journey to hell and back right
yes for sure cool then we're gonna find
something else we can do and you're
probably gonna take a big pay cut and
that's gonna be fine and we're gonna
figure it out
right
but um
the safety of of a child the safety of
your child
um is in question here and as a dad I'm
not going to have that
I'm not going to dishonor his mother and
I'm not going to run her down around him
no matter what she says about me
anytime you enter into a divorce how old
is this kid
it's about to turn 11 months too oh geez
Louise man
that's a toddler that's gonna be a tall
order man yeah will she pass a drug test
uh yes okay
it's gonna be a tall order okay
um
it might include some psychiatric
expertise it's gonna it's just gonna be
messy
that's what it comes down to
tell me about it yeah
um so here's here's the deal when you
anytime you enter into a divorce with a
little one you're instantly moving from
a short-term game to a very very long
game and it's not a game I don't like
using that language but
um
you are now
shifting influence you want this 22 or
23 or 24 year old young man
to respect his father
and that means over the next decade or
two you're gonna have to endure your
wife talking really bad about you making
accusations about you saying hard things
if that's who she ends up being
and you're gonna play a long game
because your son will one day Eyes Wide
Open see his dad respect that his mom
kept showing up and kept showing up and
kept showing up despite what the courts
did despite what all the all the hurdles
dad kept showing up okay
yeah and that's what you're gonna have
to decide if you go for short-term win
and burn his mom to the ground you're
gonna lose him too
never thought of it like that though all
right fair is that cool
yeah and I want you to make no mistake
this woman will be part of your life for
the rest of your life
sure guys you're gonna make peace with
that
and I'm doing whatever I can to get full
custody of my son because he's not safe
all right
no why why isn't that inspiring you why
is that freaking you out
the woman's so manipulative she couldn't
manipulate a squirrel to eat pineapple
instead of a peanut it's just crazy
but if if you are above board and you're
above reproach then there's nothing to
manipulate
it's true when the judge says Hey I want
all of your phone records and all of
your email records all of your DMs and
you turn yours over and she turns hers
over
right right
if you've got something to hide you got
something to hide if you don't yeah it's
super stressful there's no way this
isn't stressful and let's be honest you
knew this for a long time before you
decided to have a kid with it right
yeah yeah
I mean so none of this is surprising but
it does suck I'm sorry like just just
dad to Dad this is hard man
it's hard enough and I gotta I've got
the greatest wife and mother on planet
Earth on my side on my team and it's
hard
I've never had to do what you have to do
and I'm sorry
I guess most of the other stress would
be because my mom and dad went to the
same thing and that's a whole nother
Journey on the song my dad did Mom did
never tell my dad that I was actually
alive and it was a whole thing and I'm
like that's the one thing I never wanted
to happen I actually went like a whole
family for once and that she just
started going crazy I was like this is
not gonna go
is do you think this thing's Beyond
repair
oh yeah okay I tried making it work for
the longest and let she one minute she
wants to work with it then the next
minute she doesn't that it makes me she
does but then she'll find a find like
how I she has met a whole another guy
and starts leaving for a whole week with
him I'm like okay
your wife
yeah yeah found a guy over Tick Tock and
literally said I'll be back I'm gonna go
hang out with some girls and then I
checked their call log and then it was a
dude from Texas yeah
she's off meds yup yeah she just started
taking him because she met this guy I've
been trying to get her just to we try to
figure everything out she just wouldn't
take him yeah
that's hard man I'm sorry
I'm sorry
um keep your integrity about you keep
your um be the dad that you want your
son to be around
um even when it's hard and it's gonna
get really tough it's gonna get tough
but the more above board you stay
um and I say this fight hard for your
son
don't be passive here because this is
the health and safety of your child
right
um
but be a person of Integrity as you do
so
and I hope that the courts will honor
you and the dad you're trying to be and
the unsafe situation he is in and don't
hold anything back tell the truth always
tell the truth and get yourself a dog
fighting lawyer that will that will um
fight on your behalf
this is tough this is tough this is
tough man I'm sorry I'm sorry
um I wish this is one of those calls
that I wish I could like just tell you
this thing and it's all gonna be okay
it's not it's gonna be really tough for
a season and um so if I can help you in
any way as we as you as you travel this
this uh Gauntlet ahead of you man uh
holler back and we'll be here every step
of the way my brother